okay I have good news and mediocre news
about China and solar power and it all
makes Donald Trump's obsession with
revitalizing the coal industry even more
pathetic we've been talking about in the
era of Trump the u.s. not really being
the leader anymore in the world the US
president is no longer the leader of the
free world it's a euphemism it's not a
literal term realistically though the
leader of the free world is now German
Chancellor Angela Merkel the u.s. is not
the leader if it ever was but it's
clearly not the leader now on
alternative energy and climate Trump
pulling out of the Paris climate Accord
Trump wanting to revitalize the dying
coal industry and I've been talking
about China and India as the sort of
rising leaders in curbing climate change
and we have now learned that China has
already surpassed its solar power target
for 2020
it's 2017 they are three years ahead of
schedule they've now passed 105
gigawatts of solar power capacity not
only is that great news China is also
tweaking its forecasts to now target
adding another 45 gigawatts of solar
power just this year that's all great
the bad part is it's only 1% of all
Chinese energy because of the amount of
Chinese energy demands but it's still a
huge increase and for that we should be
glad I remember one of the biggest
conservative arguments against combating
climate change was what does it really
matter if the US is doing it because
China is not taking the appropriate
steps because they have the world's
largest population and because in part
because of that reason the world's
largest polluters sure what we do
doesn't really make a difference because
they're not going along with it now
they're way ahead of the game
they are and even though it's only 1% of
their energy they were at 0.3% of their
energy coming from solar in 2015 so
they've roughly tripled that and we also
it's important to think about this in
the context of how China works right I
mean one of the best and worst things
about China as a country is they can get
anything done at the government say-so
right China can make a decision and say
hey businesses you need to invest in
solar and they just have to say the word
and businesses in China have to invest
in solar so we have to think about that
when we see the growth that China is
able to have Western nations do have to
deal
well we have to incentivize private
corporations to do this because we have
a different system than does China but
regardless the important thing is I wish
Trump understood well I wish Trump
understood anything but what I mean here
is I wish he understood the issue of
energy as a national security issue as
an economic issue it's an issue about he
talks about America being great the u.s.
is just not the place you go to if you
want to observe aggressive and
innovative thinking about alternative
energy at the country level
yeah Tesla batteries are fascinating and
the storage of renewable energy that
they're working on very important but
you look at Israel for solar panel
technology you look at China and India
for national level replacement of fossil
fuels and it's not the United States
it's not the United States that you're
now looking to it seems like this is a
topic where there could be so much
friendly competition between countries
as well like we could say hey China you
got us on solar but we'll get you on
wind energy but it seems like Donald
Trump isn't really stepping up to the
plate because in part he's pulling out
of the Paris climate Accord in
supporting the coal industry it's like
we're not even trying oh it's there it's
just it's not even on the table that
we're gonna make big progress on this
during the Trump administration and it's
utterly pathetic but hey congratulations
to China